des heurts ce parti top départ vous avez
deux heures huit candidates ou sans
formation en boulangerie pâtisserie et
âgés de 16 à 18 ans s'affrontaient ce
jeudi au lycée hôtelier de saint quentin
en yvelines
il participait à la sélection régionale
ile de france du concours du meilleur
croissant au beurre d'isigny et chacun
avait sa petite raison pour moi bah déjà
à part d'avoir un aperçu d'un premier
concours parce que c'est le premier que
je fais et puis pour voir mes capacités
un peu aussi vont je me situe dans la
profession se mettre face à ses acquis
et s'améliorer c'est juste pour avoir de
l'expérience prendre du plaisir aussi
tester des concours ça fait toujours une
petite sensation et c'est ça qu'on
recherche en fait de l'entraînement pour
plus progressé c'est d'améliorer ma
technique est d'apprendre plus pour
espérer gagner en expérimentation
créé par l'association des professeurs
de boulangerie et la crème lait d'isigny
cette 15e édition du concours demandé
aux candidats de réaliser 24 croissant
il doit être régulier donc ça c'est un
des principaux critères la régularité du
croissant les qualités gustatives
donc on doit avoir un bon goût de
viennoiseries au beurre ils doivent
également être courbé donc
ça veut dire qu'on repli les extrémités
des viennoiseries
l'objectif pour eux il est de valoriser
leur travail leur servent à faire
puisque c'est vraiment voilà on est dans
un métier artisanal et les deux
apprentis qui ont le mieux valoriser
leur métier sont erwan du lycée hôtelier
d'etiolles et l'ivi noise salomé du
lycée de saint quentin en yvelines
ils représenteront l'île de france lors
de la finale nationale du concours les
17 et 18 novembre prochains en normandie